قالت مصادر تركيه للجزيره انه وزراء دفاع
تركيا وروسيا وسوريا اتفقوا في موسكو على
تشكيل لجان العسكريه واستخباراتيه
المشتركه تبدا اجتماعاتها نهايه الشهر
المقبل اضافه ان اللقاء وهو الاول بين
وزير الدفاع التركي والسوري منذ عام 2011
بحث قضايا بين حل الازمه السوريه وعوده
اللاجئين وما تعرف بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه
شمال سوريا
اهلا بكم كان ذلك خبر حلقتنا ونناقشه في
مسارات ثلاثه
وزير الدفاع التركيه والسوريه في ضوء
تمخضه عن تفاهمات بشان ملفات اللاجئين وما
تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه وما هي
التاثيرات التي يمكن ان يحدثها هذا اللقاء
على المواقف السياسيه للاطراف الثلاثه من
الازمه السوريه وما هي ارتداداته المحتمله
على مسارها مستقبلا
وما هي لنا كاسات والاستراتيجيه والامنيه
لهذا اللقاء فيما يخص شمال وشرق سوريا
وكيف ستتعامل الولايات المتحده مع ما تم
التوصل اليه من تفاهمات بشان
[موسيقى]
بعد قطيعه دامت 11 عاما اجتمع في موسكو
يوم الاربعاء وزراء الدفاع التركي والسوري
بحسب مصادر تركيه تحدثت للجزيره بحضور
ومشاركه نظرهما الروسي المصادر واضافه ان
الوزراء اتفقوا على تشكيل لجان مشتركه من
مسؤولي الدفاع والمخابرات ستبدا
اجتماعاتها نهايه الشهر المقبل في موسكو
تعقبها اجتماعات في انقره وفي دمشق
وبحا حسب المصادر ذاتها فان اجتماع موسكو
اتفق ايضا على اليه المشتركه لتسهيل عوده
اللاجئين السوريين بعد توفير الارضيه
المناسبه وفقا للمصادر التركيه فانه وزراء
الدفاع الثلاثه ناقشوا ايضا تصورا يضع حدا
لوجود ما تعرف بقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
شماليه سوريه
وزير الدفاع تركيا خلص يا اكار قال ان
عوده اللاجئين السوريين يجب ان تكون بشكل
طوعي وامنا ومشرف وان تركيا ابدت
استعدادها للعمل المشترك بهذا الخصوص اكار
اكد ايضا ان بلاده تؤيد استمرار التواصل
مع نظام الاسد بشكل صحي بحسب قوله وانها
تبذل جهودها في هذا الاتجاه واضاف الوزير
التركي انه في حال كانت الظروف وشروط
مناسبه فان من الممكن عقد لقاءات على
مستوى القاده وفقا تعبيره
في اول رد فعل على ما كشف عنه من تفاهمات
روسيه تركيه سوريه في موسكو خرجت في مدن
وبلدات عده شمال غرب سوريا مظاهرات
للتاكيد على التمسك بثواب الثوره السوريه
المتظاهرون طالبوا بتطبيق القرار الدولي
رقم 2000
254 القاضي بنقل السلطه في سوريا لهيئه
حكم الانتقاليه مستقله ومفوضه كما دعا
المتظاهرون المجتمع الدوليه الى عدم اعطاء
او منح اي شرعيه للنظام بعد ما تسبب في
مقتل مئات الالاف السوريين وتهجيرهم عن
مدنهم وتغيبه لالاف اخرين في السجون
والمعتقلات
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم لمناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من
اسطنبول السفير فكره وزير الدبلوماسيه
التركيه السابق امين واشنطن ستيفن
الباحث في مركز سياسه الشرق الاوسط بمعهد
بروكينس ابدا بضيفي من اسطنبول السفير
فكره اوزيل ونريد ان نفهم مغزى التوقيت
الان لماذا الان لماذا السعيد تركي الان
بهذا الشكل الى تطبيع العلاقات مع النظام
في في دمشق
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
طابت طابت اوقاتكم كما تعلمون تركيا منذ
بدايه الازمه حاول
ليحلها
بعده طرق
واخيرا كما تعلمون في مسار ستانا والثاني
ايضا في
مفاوضات جنيف لكن هذا الطرق وقد وصل الى
طريق مسدود
والتركيه يريد تنشيط هذه
المسارات هذه النشاطات همم
قدمه
للتخلص من هذه طريق المسدود همم
كما تعلمون تركيا حاليا ثلاثه مليون ونصف
همم سوري قد
يستضيفهم في في بلدهم
وفي تركيا مصالح تركيه
ومصالح سوريه قد
وافق قد تقاطع ااه في هذا الوقت كما
تعلمون تركيا تهتم
بواحده اراضي السوريه وايه حكومه نظام
سوري ايضا مهتم بواحده اراضيها
يعني هذه هذه التفاهمات تاتي في موسم
الانتخابات ايضا هل يمكن استبعاد عامل
العامل الانتخابي و و و و وفي موسم
الانتخابات هذه القضيه بالتحديد قضيه همم
ما تعرف بالقوات سوريا الديمقراطيه في
الشمال السوري وايضا اللاجئين السوريين هي
قضايا ساخنه في الانتخابات هل يمكن عزل
العامل الانتخابي عن
والله هذا لا لا اعتقد هذا متعلق
بانتخابات القادمه بالتركيه
وكما تعلمون هذا هذا الوضع لا يمكن ان
يبقى مثل هذا الى الابد
وكما تعلمون وهناك هجمات
هجمات الارهابيه همم الى تركيا همم
مرارا
يجب طبعا تركيا تهتم
بامنها الداخلي
وامنه حدوده
من همم مسار ستانا ومسار همم
انتهت يجب تنشيطها وتركيا همم من البدايه
حاول لحلها مع اتفاق
مفاوضات مع همم
الفقيه امريكيين او الغربيين لكنهم همم لم
لم يقم بواجبهم
ويتبنوا تتبنوا الفئه الارهابيه في شمال
السوريه ويريدون ان يخلق منطق ان تخلق
منطقه كما قاموا بشمال عراق
سيد سيف النار
ضيفنا ايضا واشنطن
كيف تنظر انت الى التوقيت والدفع من جانب
همم كل الاطراف المنخرطه في هذه التفاعلات
انه لابد ان نختلف مع الضيف في التركي
المحترم للامر يتالق بشكل كبير بتغيير
الظروف الامنيه على الارض في شمال سوريا
اكثر من له علاقه بالازمه السياسيه التي
يواجهها الرئيس اردوغان في الداخليه
يمر بصعوبه
والرئيس الشعبيه الرئيس
على الحدود من جانب القوات سوريا
الديمقراطيه والاطراف الكرديه الاخرى في
سوريا
في تركيا
حول عدم بقاء اللاجئين
سوري في تركيا وهذا الى حد كبير هو
النتيجه ظروف المحليه الداخليه والتحديات
التي يواجهها الرئيس اردوغان واعتقد ان
هذا له علاقه بالحد كبير بتوقيت كل هذه
التفاهمات حول التدخل العسكريه من جانبها
روسيا تستغله هذه الازمه داخل الحزب
السياسي
ازمه محليه خلق فرصه
وعلينا ان نرحل
اي عمليه دبلوماسيه مفيده همم هل في رايك
يعني تحول استراتيجي في نظره انقره للازمه
ونظره همم الاطراف الاخرى ام هي فقط نتيجه
اكراهات كما تفضلت يعني هل نشهد ان هذا
المسار يمكن ان يكون مسار مؤقتا ام مسارا
دائما وسؤاري لك
تغيير استراتيجي في غايه الاهميه
من الرئيس اردوغان وهو المسؤولون الكبار
في الحكومه التركيه الذين حاولوا في
الواقع غزوه او انهاء السياسه التركيه
السابقه
وهذا طبعا يعتبر بنسبه 180 درجه من الموقف
الذي كان عليه الرئيس
اذا ما نشهده هو تغير كبير كبير وهو
تغيرته تاثيرات الكبيره على ملايين
السوريين الذين في شمال سوريا
وتستمر بالحصول على المظله الامنيه تقدمها
لهم تركيا وبالتالي هل تغيير كبير في
السياسه وساكنوا التاثيرات الكبيره على
الاستقرار على الارض على
التاثرات على الظروف الانسانيه على الارض
وعلي وعلينا انظر بيتمعن حولك تطور هذه
العمليه لنتاكد بان لها
المعاناه على الملايين والملايين من
المدنيين الذين قد يتاثرون بذلك تركيا
سياده السفير فكره اسير لها همم حواجز
امنيه كبيره همم في الشمال السوري والشمال
الشرقي همم الى اي مدى تمثل هذه الهواجس
اولويه على مساله اللاجئين
والاربعه ونصف او اكثر مليون سوري الذين
يعيشون في الشمال السوري وهمم تركيا هي
التي تحفظ انهم في الواقع
تركيا تركيا اول كل شيء
واجب عليه ان تامين امنه
[موسيقى]
في
في حدود شماله بين تركيا
وسوريا وهو يفتخذ
ويقوم بالترتيبات اللازمه
لامنها
هذه
التوقيت للمفاوضات مع نظام السوري همم لا
يتم متعلق
للرفعيه الشعبيه همم اردوان لا حاجه لا
حاجه له همم ان يقوم مثل هذه الامور للرفع
همم لرفع شعبيهتها تركيا كما تعلمون منذ
سنتين بدات تطبيع مع الدول الخليج همم
امارات والسعوديه وهمم مصر وهم ما يستمر
وهذا اييه وهذا هذا المشكله يجب ان
يجب ان ينتهي باسرع وقت ممكن
وخلالها هذه روسيا سابقا كان ااا مش
ملائمه مثل هذا لكن الان روسيا تبنى ل- اا
اتمنى لترتيب هذه اللقاء
والتركيه طبعا كل شيء في وقته همم في وقت
مناسب قام بهذه اللقاء
وفوضوا همم وافقوا ان يستمر هذه اللقاءات
وذلك اللقاءات لمصلحه التركيه ومصلحه همم
مصلحه سوريه وتركيا همم طبعا همم
شرط همم
لازم همم ان يؤمن عند عوده السوريين الى
بلادهم امنهم وامامهم ايه منذ 10 سنوات قد
حماهم كيف طازجه الان لكن وزير الدفاع
يتحدث عن عوده طوعيه امنه ومشرفه
مثلا تقول ان العوده التوعيه التي قيل
عنها مسبقا كانت طويلا تكن طوعيه ابدا بل
كانت تحت تهديد السلاح كيف ستوفر تركيا
هذه العوده
عن تسليم الامن في مناطق سيطرت تركيا في
الشمال السوري لان النظام السوري كيف
سيحدث هذا نريد ان نفهم
حاليا حاليا ااه اكثر من نصف مليون سوري
قد عاد الى
قسم قسم
[موسيقى]
تحميه تركيه في شمال سوريا
وطبعا ااا تركيا هذه المفاوضات حاليا تحت
المفاوضات
وهذا الموضوع ايضا يدور الموضوع
وتركيا همم يطلب منهم همم جزريا ان همم
القيام بتامين امنهم عند عودتهم همم الى
همم الى ترابهم
لكن مثلا التسليم المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها الجيش التركي في الشمال السوري
للنظام كيف يمكن ان يضمن ذلك
حياه سلامه من يعيشون في هذه المناطق طبعا
طبعا في روسيا ااا وسيط بهذه اللقاء طبعا
لتركيا سيطلب من جانب سوري
الضمانات الضمانات ال- اا قويه
لتامين امن همم امني هذا همم
هذا ضيوفنا همم طبعا همم حاليا همم في همم
حسب الاتفاقيه همم قد وصل همم وصل الطرفان
ان يستمر وان همم
يتفاوضوا الشروط والضروس
كفاح ضد الارهاب بجميع نواياها
وداعش وكذا همم
طبعا همم يثبت طرفان سي يقترحان
اا حسب
تقوم طرفان هذه المبادئ فيما يتعلق بمطار
بقوه سوريا الديمقراطيه همم ما تصورك انت
لما يمكن الوصول اليه بين تركيا والنظام
في دمشق
والله همم في همم في همم هذه همم فئه
موجوده في شمال العراق همم تحت حمايه همم
امريكا همم نفس التهديد لنظام السوري
ونظام تركيا همم طبعا همم هناك همم
نظام السوري همم لم تقطع علاقاتها همم بعض
هذه الفئه لكن في النهايه
همم
يتجهون يتجهون ل- همم
للتفريق همم السوريه همم السوريه نظام
السوري همم لم ترضى همم تقسيم همم بلده
[موسيقى]
سيد ستيفن هايد من يعني اذا كانت كما قال
السفير من هذا جزء من
يعني استراتيجيه جديده وهو العوده الى
علاقات طبيعيه عوده الى علاقات ما قبل
2001 10
الان كيف تنظر الولايات المتحده الى هذا
هذا التقارب التركي وهذا الاتجاه التركي
ناحيه النظام السوري وناحيه الازمه
السوريه وخصوصا قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه
اعتقد انما ترهل الولايات المتحده هو ان
هناك صعوبات كبيره لتحقيق الظروف التي
والشروط التي ناقشتها مع السفير التركي
نظام الاسد قدم التزامات عديده في السابق
للتامين امن اللاجئين العائدين
والمقاتلين معارضه الذين
النظام كسر كله وعوده
يقدمون احمد سلامه
اشخاص يعملون في المنطقه
من الضروري جدا وجهه نظر امريكيه المحافظه
على القدرات لمواصله حمله لحقل هزيمه
بتنظيم الدوله اذا ما حصل تغيير في الوضع
السياسي في شمال سوريا لا يقوم على اتفاق
بل على تدخل عسكري فان القلق هو ان ذلك
سيقلل ويخفض قدره مواجهه والحقل زينه
بتنظيم الدوله ولا يقدم الاستقرار اضافه
هناك قلق شديد حول التاثيرات الانسانيه
اذا ما عادا نظام الاسد الى شمال سوريا
همم
اذا حدث وتم تفاهم بين تركيا
وروسيا وسوريا على ان يتولى النظام السوري
مناطق قوات سوريا الديمقراطيه ماذا ستفعل
الولايات المتحده
النظام السوري سيحارب ايضا تنظيم الدوله
بسيطه جدا
لعب الدوره ضعيفا جدا في مواجهه تنظيم
الدوله بالفضله
التنظيم الدوله
التاريخ
في مركز سياسه الشرق الاوسطنز ضيفنا من
واشنطن ونشكر الضيف من اسطنبول السفير
فكره
الى هنا وصلنا لنهايه هذه الحلقه من
برنامج مراد الخبر
[موسيقى]